trop solide au québec qu'est ce que vous
avez dit là j'en reconnais comme il
était principal tiff la mobilisation
sans précédent face aux grands froids et
manifestations pour dénoncer le manque
d'hébergement
c'est une mesure d'hébergement d'urgence
combien vous avez chez vous 2 mètres
carrés tu te rends son peuple vous avez
beaucoup de chance d'avoir pu acheter 1
200 m² dans un quartier n'est plus coté
tard si c'est pas de la chance par wayne
je bosse en chine ça quand il s'agit de
boue fenosa look lalalala ils sont tous
là mais pour ce qu'ils payent un loyer
d'un seul coup j'ai vu personne qui sont
où ils sont où tu vas partager ton
espace vital avec quelqu'un 1
déjà qu'ils supportent pas contre
l'atome large avec celui de notre fille
ouvre cette porte
jean voulu la grosse et belle si tu
m'avais fait de petits livres oeil de
plus ceux-ci dubreuil soyez les
bienvenus
si vous voulez rester il va falloir tous
prendre un bain ça un tout petit peu fou
france si tout le monde avait voté comme
moi j'ai bien connu les gens de droite
n'ont pas de coeur beaucoup de merde à
laisser ça casse pas les travers tes
racines à fond rien de la journée
les toqués tour in aménas ardente
ailleurs vu par les manières vous
l'embarras bien sûr qu'on est fier
d'avoir voté à gauche pour la suite
arrêté
allo une dame avec un chien quelle race
non pas le chien de dames